el presidente chileno gabriel boric
presentó este viernes una reforma
tributaria destinada a financiar al
menos la mitad de su programa de
profundas reformas sociales en el país
con esta reforma tributaria se pretende
recaudar al menos un 4,1 por ciento del
producto interior bruto que equivale
aproximadamente a 12 mil millones de
dólares la reforma incluye mecanismos
para evitar la elusión de impuestos una
actualización del royalty minero nuevos
tributos al patrimonio y también
correcciones mayores entre otras medidas
se aplicará sobre todo un impuesto a la
riqueza al 3% más rico del país aquellas
fortunas por encima de los 5 millones de
dólares mientras que aquellos que están
entre 10 y 15 millones de dólares de
patrimonio tendrán una tasa de un 1%
esta tasa se incrementará al 18 por
ciento para aquellas fortunas mayores de
15 millones de dólares se trata de una
reforma tributaria destinada a lograr
una mayor equidad una mayor igualdad y
cohesión social en el país afirmó el
mandatario mientras que su ministro de
haciendo a mario marcel uno de los más
destacados del gabinete afirmó que esta
reforma tributaria más que un pacto
fiscal para separar a los buenos y los
malos en el país trata de basar un
desarrollo más justo en chile a través
de un acuerdo social más amplio y más
justo para todos